[Musique]
tu confrontés à une réalité un peu
complexe et que pour faire une série sur
le rap il va falloir trouver des
rappeurs qui savent jouer la comédie et
la première question c'est est ce que
c'est possible quoi pour être très
honnête
le déclencheur c'est la rencontre avec
nous sert mansaly qui joue le rôle de ma
star je suis schizophrène monde en tout
ce que je fais ce que je suis jeune
acteur joue c'est un rappeur et je suis
aussi auteur j'écris des ddd des titres
pour coursan artistes projet validé
c'était une vraie ambiance parfaite
entre les corps de métier en valeur
[Musique]
là je voulais des gens qui soient pas
forcément très identifiable par le
public notant trappeur de manière à ce
que justement elles puissent
s'identifier aux personnages
je voulais pas non plus que ce soit un
rappeur connu qui soit le héros de la
série pour pâques ce rappeur vampirise
l'image de la série sert je voulais pas
que ça devienne la série de la crim la
série de kool shen la série de mignot
puis surtout il fallait qu'on est
quelqu'un qui a une crédibilité de
rappeurs absolument incontestable qu'ils
soient charismatique emblématique soit
qui représente un rap rappeur
d'aujourd'hui quoi un million de
questions me viennent en tête mass start
et le boss du rap game chantant ta voix
dans lequel je connais ton parcours
parker tu sais que dans l'afrique on
t'aime on observe en salle et escreet ce
qui est le patron de demolition qui
travaille aussi avec franck sur la série
qui m'ont contacté pour savoir s'il
était intéressé pour faire le pour
participer au casting h et arrivée on
essaie alors qu'on avait vu peut-être
200 mecs et puis se passe un truc et que
ce mec est un roman une pièce il se
passe un truc il prend de la place
on commence à faire des essais et puis
là c'est moins bien que ben oui c'est
mon bien parce que parce que ce serait
trop facile d'être tombé sur un mec qui
était un rappeur d'exception est un
grand acteur
il parie que je français de me dire je
vais pas le lâcher quoi j'aime mettre
sur son dos on va travailler beaucoup
c'est ce qu'on a fait ça permet à m
si tu es trop en france contre aux
spectateurs dont il s'avère l'année ça
permet de me préparer la tension pour la
somme d'après j'avoue que c'est un
travail que j'ai adoré faire parce que
j'ai j'ai pas l'habitude de ça tu veux
travailler avec des acteurs confirmés
ça lui met la pression dans le salon
malgré le temps d'être une crise puisque
la nuit va être longue
il vaut mieux opter pour la méthode une
prise et c'est très bête dès la première
je vais monter le curseur et je peux
gagner du temps et moi j'avais trop
comme faisait ça t'as un mec qui a
jamais joué de sa vie et qui te dit je
suis ton gars je serai là à l'heure que
tu me dis j'ai faim dis moi comment je
dois fois que parce que je vais pas
faire le plan de la grue la voiture qui
passe est un côté d'entendre ap d'abord
je vais je quitte à me sentir que mettre
en conditions potentiellement est un peu
angoissé tu vois
prendre un peu ton souffle époux petit
va on parle de la complexité de ce
personnage et il m'expliquer pourquoi
c'est important que les gens voient mes
faiblesses avant de forcément me voir
vainqueur qui réussit tout ce qui fait
c'était vachement instructif et c'est
vrai que ça a été un gros déclic pour
moi à ce moment là et je me rappelle la
répète d'après je suis revenu c'était
totalement différent je pense qu'il
pourra vous confirmez c'était vraiment
un beau souvenir valider une création
originale à découvrir en avant-première
en ce moment sur my canal